what up space fam goes in here for anime
uproar and today we are going to be
taking a close look at hundred of his
powers and how strong he is in relation
to the other characters in the series if
you want to see more demon slayer
content on this channel make sure to
smash that like button to let me know
and let me know what characters
strengths you'd like to see broken down
next if you haven't be sure to subscribe
and ring that notification bell so you
actually get notified when you would
even say our videos drop for more Demon
Slayer content and crucial updates
follow us on Twitter and Instagram at
anime uproar if you're interested in
discussing the new chapters live with us
soon after they come out you can follow
us on Twitch just look up anime uproar
and follow us in the near future we'll
be talking about the new demon slayer
chapters along with the seven deadly
sins black clover attack on Titan and my
hero academia chapters so I hope to see
you there you can also find the link to
our twitch in the description there will
be manga spoilers in this video you've
been warned now without further ado
let's jump into it from the beginning
town zeros been pretty special and
strong even as far back as the first
chapter an untrained punch it almost
managed to catch me off guard and hit
him in the head with his axe goo a
hashida is shocked that this
inexperienced kid devised the plan in
the heat of the moment that almost got
him later he also surpasses Sakura G's
expectations as Sakura explains he did
not intend to let Tonto enter the final
selection that is why he set a goal that
he thought tons you know wouldn't be
able to reach he told him to split a
giant boulder with his sword a seemingly
impossible feat for tan judo except once
again ton zero surpass people's
expectations he managed to split the
boulder that was much much bigger not to
mention heavier than him in size so
kanji tells ton zero that he's an
amazing child before he gives him his
blessing to go to the final selection as
we know tons ittle goes on to pass the
final selection and after beating a
number of demons he even goes on to beat
the former lower bloom six kill guy at
this point he seems to be able to almost
beat anyone but his power finally hits
its current ceiling during his fight
against lower Moon 5 Louie
tonzura is completely overpowered by Yui
he even unlocks his new dance of the
fire-god
style and teams up with mezack o who
unlocks her blood burst demon technique
and it's still not enough to be druid
who he dispatches his own head before
tangelos blade cuts through his neck Rui
is about to finish time to her off when
GU comes and saves him at this point
view illustrates just how much the gap
between his and ton zero skill level is
Q effortlessly stops through his strikes
attacks with this original breath of
water eleventh form he created his own
form and without moving he renders
through his best attacks useless then in
a moment with a bored look on his face
he slices off through his head before he
can even react he just flexed on the
overpowered demon that was wrecking ton
zero even though Tundra was working
together with his sister and they both
just got power upgrades at this point in
the manga time zero ngey or nowhere
close to each other in strength
similarly when upper Moon 3 akiza shows
up Hunter has to rely on the fire pillar
and Goku to save him all Tiger can do is
watch from the sidelines because he's
too weak and injured to do anything but
get in then go lose weight I guess I
even calls ton zero a weakling at this
point however ton 0 has protagonist
powers and as a result he is probably
one of the most rapid rates of growth in
the entire series by the time a COS
attacks again
tangelo has become a lot stronger he was
with him and when he sees times you to
respond to all causes attacks he thinks
to himself that tons of those techniques
have improved a lot he says it's no joke
to say that ton zeroes power matches
that of a pillar so this newcomer who
not too long ago was too weak to stand a
chance against lower moon 5 is now
already at pillar level at the age of 16
to put this in perspective
EU is 21 at this point and yet tangela
already seems to have reached a similar
level even though he's a relative novice
gu actually recounts the day he first
ran into time zero and how he could do
nothing but cry and beg for his sister's
life now he can fight among the pillars
as an equal even Icaza who previously
called hundred a week has to accept that
he's not humana fests a mark and his
power increases but Icaza can still
easily keep up with him so in order to
beat Icaza
tonzura is going to have to surpass even
he used power for the first time during
the fight hundred or drastically
improves control gains access to the
see-through world something that the
strongest pillar is like Mui Chino and
Gil may have access to s tundra explains
this ability allows him to see someone's
whole body as if it was transparent and
it allows Tonto to move his body faster
than he ever did before to be even more
specific in this see-through world
movement intuition innovation speed
dramatically increases it allows the
user to observe the movements of his
opponents lungs and contractions of
their blood vessels and the contractions
of their muscles more clearly and
quickly - obviously this means that one
can predict his opponent's moves quicker
because the contractions of the body
will give hints internally before the
actual attack is launched then there's
the problem of battle spirit which Akasa
can sense battle spirit seems to be
something like the fiery will to win or
once killing intent ah casaya is amazing
at sensing this which is how he is able
to respond so quickly to attacks and
dodge them he was having trouble even
cutting through ah kisses flesh and aqus
I eventually just punches you sword and
breaks it if that ain't a flex I don't
know what is here's a guy who spent his
whole life developing his swordsmanship
skills he's considered one of the best
swordsmen in the world and Alcazar just
broke his sword by punching it Octus is
about to kill you before tan judo comes
in and cuts off all kisses hand tan
general has attained a clear minded
state where he can fight without giving
off battle spirit or killing intent as
GU points out he was saved by tangelo
Tantra went from being practically
useless and needing pillars to save him
to saving a pillar himself now that
Tantra has awakened this new clear
minded state every single cell in our
castles body down to his cheek hair is
telling him to kill tanjit off right now
we've never seen him have this kind of
reaction to Ren Goku or Gyu which
suggests that ton zero in a relatively
short period of time has went from being
a novice to surpassing both of these
strong pillars for a time - no time
seems to have considerably slowed down
within the see-through world this is in
part because tan zero is moving so fast
himself and as an added bonus he is able
to
his presence in his clear minded state
so that he can sneak up on a casa
despite that something hilarious happens
he tells a casa he's going to cut off
his head before he goes and does it
while GU is thinking what we are all
thinking when he says why would you call
his name out like that [ __ ]
nevertheless time zero has reached such
a level that even though he warned
Acosta beforehand he still succeeds in
cutting off his head i cuz' hopes to use
time zeros battle spirit to sense him
and dodge him
but since ton 0 has no battle spirit at
this point Alcazar's caught completely
off guard what's even more impressive is
that Icaza and all his centuries of
existence has never seen a human with no
battle spirit and yet Panchito is
skilled enough to have achieved this
state Alcazar compared it to fighting
against a plant because it points out
that ton zero has even surpassed his
speed ton zeroes eyes have no hatred or
anger in them there is no intent to
murder or fight the thing captured in
his eyes
thinks Icaza is most likely the supreme
territory that Alcazar always wanted it
has to be the state of anata for this
video I had to quickly see what he meant
by the state of anata so I looked it up
in Buddhism anata is adoption of
non-self thus it seems that in a sense
in this state Tundra is no longer an
individual he is one with the flow of
the universe just like a plant
after tun zeros impressive performance
he starts to crash at this point
Angelo's eyes are aching his muscles are
getting numb and his body is at its
limit
he can't maintain the state in a lot of
ways this day reminds me of the all
trans thing form from Dragon Ball super
in the sense that you don't think as
much as you just react but you also can
come in and out of the form now back to
Akasaka Zoe's body even though he should
be dead keeps moving he could have
actually recovered and beat both ton
zero and you like he decided to die
gracefully instead after his memories
came back
that brings us to tangelos current skill
level when kiria the current head of the
demon slayers is asked if they should
send GU and tundra to demon moon one he
says they will continue towards moves on
he says this partially because he is
sure that yo mace anime Muccino and
ganya will be able to defeat upper moon
one on their own
however the implication is also that
puncture was strong enough to confront
Mouzon at this point at least with the
help of other pillars the obviously
wouldn't have sent him there if he was
just going to get wrecked after showing
up so it seems that Tundra is quite
strong now he is definitely among the
level of the strongest pillars in the
series his dance of the fire-god style
was suggested to be directly related to
the breath of the Sun which is the
strongest breath from which all other
breaths originate there are also clear
parallels between tan judo and yo Deecee
the breath of the Sun user that almost
killed Mouzon and is considered to be
the strongest demon slayer in history
both tangible and your each sheet use
what appears to be the breath of the
sun' style both have similar markings on
their forehead and both wear the same
earrings it almost seems like tan judo
is destined to finish what you're
teaching and finish off moves on once
and for all
in a way he seems to be your ichi
successor thus I think that tan Jiro
definitely has the potential especially
considering his insanely rapid growth to
become the strongest character in the
entire series however as of now we can
say that during the time he's in that
clear minded non-self state he at least
surpasses ran Goku GU and even a casa
however the issue is that this state can
only be maintained for a limited amount
of time and then it causes serious
exhaustion to tangelos body thus if he
doesn't finish off his opponent as was
the case with a casa he can find himself
in serious trouble so we can't just say
that tangelo is overall stronger than a
casa
but like esken or in the one mode for
that short window of time tangelo can
reach that supreme level that Alcazar
never did because of the nature of this
ability I wouldn't be too quick to
assume that Tundra has passed the level
of Guillaume a for instance who can also
access the see-through world although he
had help
Yomi was able to catch up err moon one
who is stronger than a casa off-guard he
hit him with this iron ball took off his
arm and this led to a chain of events
that eventually seems to have led to his
defeat in Chapter 175 Yomi also did
something we didn't see from anyone else
so far
Yomi was able to control his blood
circulation and thus deceive upper moon
one who also has access to the
see-through world multiple times as he
was fighting he was also able to save
his comrades
not to mention that he fought for a long
time at an extremely high level while
time zero still can maintain his non
self state for too long for these
reasons I wouldn't yet put time zero on
Gil Mays level or on Moos odds Mouzon is
no doubt going to be stronger than both
of them but working together there is a
hope that they'll be able to pull off a
win especially when we take into account
the way in which characters can rapidly
grow in a fierce battle still though
keep in mind that Gil May is 27 years
old and according to upper Moon one he
just gained access to the see-through
world during their fight Kanjar was 16
and he already gained access to that
world so even though I think Yomi is
still stronger for now if Tantra keeps
up his rate of growth it won't be long
before he even surpasses the strongest
pillar in strength so that space vamp is
how strong Tantra is at the moment and
how strong he can get if he keeps up his
current rate of growth as I said before
I believe that in a way
tangelo is a successor of your each
sheet there is a reason he wears his
earrings after all as a result I think
he will eventually also achieve
strongest Demon Slayer levels of power I
believe that he will even surpass your
ichi
since your each he mentioned before that
someday children will be born who
surpass him and his brother Tundra our
protagonist definitely seems like he's
going to be one of those children but
for now I look forward to enjoying the
ride and seeing how he gets there just
like with Luffy and the one piece
anyways thanks so much for watching this
video if you enjoyed it make sure to
smash that like one to let me know if
you haven't be sure to subscribe and
ring that notification bell so you
actually get notified when new Demon
Slayer videos come out leave suggestions
for what other Demon Slayer videos you
would like to see in the comments for
even more Demon Slayer greatness and
crucial updates you can follow us on
twitter and instagram at anime uproar a
big thank you goes out to our patrons
over on patreon who help make videos
like this one possible I especially want
to thank our pro hero to your patrons
the one and only Gilgamesh nothing but a
fan Jason Wilson kings eldritch angel
Cruz Steelers poet Pablo and atropos
Wraith and are the one tier patrons the
ones who stand atop all clans Steven and
Greta al-hola autumn Maddie Mac 239 and
makoto-kun
if you enjoy our work you could support
more of it by going over to patreon calm
animals lore and becoming a patron today
for as little as one dollar if you do so
you'll get your name featured in future
videos alongside these pillars right
here and you'll even get access to our
private patron only discord so check out
patreon.com/lenguin
you can now also join the YouTube
channel and support more content that
way if you prefer you'll still get the
same great benefits no matter where you
choose to support us anyways thanks
again for everything and until next time
see you space Cowboys
[Music]